[Musica]
fin dalle scuole medie era il 2008 però
sempre al centro dell'attenzione
ma mai da solo sempre insieme ai miei
compagni di banco
lorenzo federico e andrea
eravamo come nodi tu la stessa corda che
condividevano
esperienze
emozioni e penne rosse
siamo cresciuti sotto l'attenta
supervisione
di professori molto esigenti
ricordo come se fosse ieri
la professoressa di matematica una donna
tutta d'un pezzo che esigeva rigore e
precisione in qualsiasi cosa facessimo
anche nel portare le penne rosse
e mentre noi iniziavamo a muovere i
nostri primi passi al di fuori di quelle
mura scolastiche
dall'altra parte del mondo
stava per accadere la tempesta perfetta
mi riferisco alla crisi economica del
definita la seconda crisi dopo la grande
depressione
ha devastato l'economia mondiale il
risultato
penso che ce lo ricordiamo tutti ha
causato un forte crollo del mercato
immobiliare è una grande un grande
aumento della disoccupazione
altezza alimentare alla disuguaglianza
di reddito in molti hanno perso la
fiducia nelle banche e nei governi
e sappiamo tutti molto bene che cosa
significa perdere la fiducia in qualcuno
immagina il tuo compagno di banco che
esca con il tuo grande amore questo in
tirsi sgomenti e provare a colmare quel
vuoto è praticamente impossibile
vero
lo sapeva molto bene
satoshi nakamoto vi starete chiedendo
questo punto se fosse un mio ex compagno
di classe
e mi devo dire che purtroppo non lo è
stato perché è uno dei personaggi più
eclettici e misteriosi del nostro tempo
un personaggio che è riuscito a colmare
il grande solco creato dalla sfiducia
nel sistema economico e finanziario
utilizzando
l'open source
il bello dell'open source e che riesce
mettendo insieme le conoscenze a fare
quello che un singolo non riuscirebbe a
fare
noi non sappiamo c'è stato ci fosse un
solo soggetto
un team di persone
ma l'unica cosa che sappiamo con
certezza è che è stato in grado di
abbattere la prima pedina dell'unico
potere che per millenni non è mai
cambiato il potere di conio dando vita a
bitcoin un sistema di moneta
crittografica capace di escludere gli
intermediari finanziari e di dare per la
prima volta il danaro in totale
controllo di chi lo possiede
questo
l'open source è davvero
una fiamma da alimentare con idee e
conoscenze
ed è il suo valore ciò di cui dobbiamo
preoccuparci
il potere di conio
è stato da sempre nelle mani di poteri
centrali
e non di rado capitava che gli stessi
imperatori mentissero sulla quantità di
oro e d argento presente nelle monete ma
il popolo riponeva la propria fiducia
nelle sue mani anche perché diciamocelo
non è che avessero molta scelta
e la stessa cosa succedeva quando al
posto degli imperatori c'erano organi di
governo eletti democraticamente che per
motivi economici o politici decidevano
quando e quanta moneta a coniare facendo
salire o scendere il prezzo di
quest'ultima
ma satoshi non ha fatto tutto questo da
solo
potete stare tranquilli nessuna magia
nera segreta o computer quantistici ha
utilizzato una mailing list e dei forum
per rendere open source la più grande
scoperta del nostro secolo
ha dato all'umanità uno strumento di
libertà che non aveva mai avuto e non
l'ha utilizzata per dare per avere nobel
per la matematica
io sono stato spesso geloso di ciò che
era mio e quindi come te in questo
momento mi sono chiesto ma perché dovrei
dare la mia penna rossa a qualcuno di
cui non conosco neanche l'identità
la risposta è che la tua penna rossa
darla a qualcuno che non conosci può
essere rischioso
sicuramente ma sapere esattamente come
questa viene utilizzata
perché open source ti fa capire che non
c'è più bisogno di riporre la tua
fiducia in qualcuno o in qualcosa
satoshi
ha elaborato questo
questa tecnologia molto complessa ma
non la data all'umanità per
per dare una dimostrazione di se stesso
lui
ha fatto sì che una comunità di
sviluppatori nonostante lui si fosse
defilato portasse avanti il suo progetto
è arrivato a questo punto magari ti
chiederai bene ma se open source può
essere davvero sicuro beh questa è la
prima domanda che mi sono posto nel
momento in cui inizia aprire il primo
libro di su questa tecnologia
pensa che
al suo massimo la brooks in di bitcoin
ha tenuto al sicuro più di 800 10
miliardi di dollari
e nonostante abbiano provato più volte
ad attirarla a svuotarla di tutti i
fondi nessuno è mai riuscito a rubare
neanche un centesimo
e dopo
averti raccontato la storia di satoshi
continuo a racconti fatti della sua
sicurezza
perché l'abruzzo in di bitcoin è così
sicura perché tutti i nodi che la
compongono scambiano informazioni tra di
loro esattamente come io lorenzo
federico andrea facevamo con le penne
rosse a scuola tutti questi nodi
distribuiscono alle loro informazioni
creando un gigantesco archivio
e dopo averti raccontato la storia di
satoshi
e quella l'esempio di bitcoin
è importante che ti dico ti dica cosa io
ho reso open source
sono passati un po di anni dei banchi
delle scuole medie ovviamente
mi sono ritrovato nelle aule grandi e
dispersive delle università
e lì non c'erano più federico lorenzo e
andrea a scambiare con me le loro penne
rosse
ero da solo
ti dico la verità
non ero non mi sentivo al massimo del
mio potenziale
poi un giorno
il totale casualità
incontrare una persona che mi raccontò
la storia di satoshi e da quel giorno mi
sembrava di essere tornato indietro di
anni
da lì decisi di dividermi le giornate
studiando il diritto e l'informatica due
cose completamente opposte
dopo qualche mese mi ritrovai a girare
per l'italia insieme ai più grandi
esperti del settore
immaginando in quel momento cosa fossero
per in me adulto quelle penne rosse
beh insomma ero maturato un po anche la
barba
lo si nota insomma
eppure
quelle penne rosse però rimase sempre le
stesse
ma c'era una cosa che era cambiata
la quantità di inchiostro che c'era
all'interno
da quel momento in poi
ho cercato di pensare fuori dagli schemi
e cercare di capire davvero cosa io
potessi fare
così avendo in contatto con tutti questi
esperti decisi di creare uno strumento
condiviso che racchiudesse tutte le
penne rosse di tutti questi esperti in
un unico luogo digitale dove chiunque
sarebbe potuto entrare
e capire esattamente di che cosa stiamo
parlando
era un'idea veramente folle all'inizio
tutti con le proprie aziende tutti con
le proprie idee
eppure quella che era un'idea folle che
è dimostrata una realtà
tangibile
mi sono ritrovato con tutte queste penne
rosse in un unico luogo
che erano state in grado di costruire
qualcosa che io da solo e neanche gli
altri da soli sarebbero stati in grado
di costruire
tutto ciò che oggi c'è intorno a noi
in realtà
ma un tempo è stato il sogno di qualcuno
oggi
toma di raccontato del sogno di satoshi
di bitcoin
del teteks è stato il sogno dei suoi
organizzatori
e il club è stato il mio sogno
ma tutti hanno in comune un approccio
l'open source
lascia che la tua penna rossa
diventi anche lo strumento di qualcun
altro
e che sia la base per costruire un
domani che da soli non saremmo in grado
di costruire
[Musica]
[Applauso]